today's the day our field trip to the
Stingray migration ray migration
migration is about going oh oh which is
where your bra how do the stingrays all
know where to go
instinct something deep inside you that
feels so familiar that have to listen to
it
oh my mom my dad I have a family we will
never forget you Dory listen to you I
miss them you know what that feels like
oh isn't it great no I'm gonna be
totally back
can you help me sorry not a great
swimmer I think it's one beautifully oh
yes story yes your friends know it was
so much fun cuz I tell you a story and
then you'd completely forget about it
and then I get to tell it to you over
and over again I'm looking for my family
are you crazy
it's too dangerous pants and mommy Oh
Neptune I'm sorry
I got a blink how do you hold your eyes
open that long
hello hey you hi can you help me yeah
mm-hmm not good
sleek swimming I'm sure this was a
one-time thing
so can we just all go back to Dory dory
I remembered something